un printemps de vent sec et froid des
conditions difficiles dont se seraient
bien passés les grands agriculteurs du
québec parce qu'ils ont déjà bien des
problèmes à régler leur manque de main
d'oeuvre est flagrant comme ici dans les
champs de vaiges pro un des gros
producteurs maraîchers obéit aux
lauréats nombre important son orgue et
osorio est un des rares mexique est au
travail
arrivé le 12 avril et après deux
semaines de quarantaine il installe
aujourd'hui le système d'irrigation
alors que normalement ils planterait des
oignons l'entreprise doit s'ajuster
car seulement 34 de ses 180 travailleurs
étrangers sont arrivés on a onze a
confirmé pour cette semaine c'est qu'ils
vont rentrer mercredi ou jeudi je crois
puis après ça les eaux on sait pas
dans luz et nous ont produit deux
millions de barquettes de l'issue par
semaine les guatémaltèques sont presque
tous au rendez vous mais ce sont les
mexicains qui tarde à arriver chez weiss
bros la bataille est ainsi ces gaz a été
investi beaucoup d'argent dans un champ
il faudra avoir des gens qui vont aimer
des tantôt pour la récolter sa
production d'eau c'est que la fonction
publique fonctionne au ralenti au
mexique en raison de la pandémie et leur
permis de travail sont compliquées à
obtenir ce qu'elle est potes ça doivent
décider aujourd'hui c'est est ce que
c'est un ps que je pleure depuis à
quelles capacités
les travailleurs étrangers représentent
30 % de la main-d'oeuvre agricole au
québec et il en manque actuellement 5000
dans nos champs on va ajouter à ce que
les agriculteurs donne 1 100 dollars par
semaine pour vous encourager à mener
donner un coup de main d'un auchan lui
paie acp a reçu 8900 candidature à la
suite de cette annonce sauf que pour
l'instant seulement 164 personnes ont
été placées chez vais-je pro laurent
gagnon est un des deux seuls étudiants
embauchés
parce que former des travailleurs sans
expérience qui ne seront peut-être pas
disponible tout l'été n'est pas
intéressant et aussi parce que le
programme a ses défauts il est destiné
aux gens qui font au salaire minimum
mais dans une structure salariale d'une
entreprise que ce soit une ferme à
l'achat gunino
il ya des gens qui dans une 25 50 75
cents de plus que salaire minimum
donc ces gens là se retrouvent demain
matin très défavorisé par rapport à ça
vespro a aussi dû mettre en place une
série de mesures pour protéger ses
employés du virus distribution de
masques prise de température
l'entreprise a aussi doublé le nombre
d'autobus pour transporter ces
travailleurs journaliers venus de
montréal
ils sont maintenant un parent siège
plutôt que deux la paix scénario qui
peut m'arriver nous c'est un scénario
aussi la contamination d'un polype qu'on
ferme les usines pendant deux semaines
trois semaines parce que on n'est pas
utilisable impossible de conserver une
faible hausse et s'est fait total fait
que sa voix chiffrier en moyenne à 4 à 5
millions de pertes par semaine coût des
mesures pour éviter ce cauchemar
trente-deux mille dollars par semaine
il ya plein intervenants qui travaillent
jour et nuit dans ce milieu là qu'ils
ont fait face à la pandémie
et ils ont eu raison des réalités qui
sont totalement différentes de ce que
c'était près pandémie fixe c'est logique
quand quelque part qu'on puisse voir une
augmentation tri vous ne rêvez donc pas
si vous trouvez vos légumes plus cher
ces jours-ci faut comprendre qu'en ce
temps ici la majorité des légumes
viennent de californie le juste le taux
de changes le dollar canadien a perdu
les 12 14 15 pour ça se fait qu'il y eu
ce soit ça se répercute immédiatement
bientôt les champs reprendront leurs
couleurs chez vais-je prou comme
ailleurs au québec et acheter les
légumes locaux coûtera moins cher pour
le consommateur
les grands producteurs maraîchers eux
s'apprêtent à vivre un des étés les plus
stressants de leur vie
[Musique]
mais pour les plus petits producteurs
c'est tout le contraire
johan breton cultive aujourd'hui une
quarantaine de variétés de légumes dans
sa petite ferme maraîchère bio depuis
ses débuts en 2009
jamais les affaires n'auront été aussi
bonnes que maintenant il ya eu une fin
amère nahman et le ça était fou les
abonnements accueille en plus de vendre
ses légumes dans un marché local elle
nourrira sept étaient 175 familles avec
ses paniers une augmentation de 45% par
rapport à l'année dernière
les paniers nous ça va commencer mi juin
puis déjà fin avril début mai on est
complet c'est comme les religions les
gens ont le goût de soummam le
commentaire que j'ai je sais comment ben
ça fait une couple d'années j'y pense et
puis là je me dis que c'est le bon
moment
c'est exactement ce que s'est dit
natalité trop nouvelle clients de johan
aller dans les épiceries actuellement
c'est un peu complexe parce que bon on
les laisse pas la distanciation et tout
fait que je me disais non moi je préfère
le concept locale
c'est surtout le volet bio et en même
temps mais j'avais le goût d'encourager
quelqu'un de la place ici c'est plus
important que jamais qu'on change un peu
des habitudes d'achat pour acheter
québécois l'appel du gouvernement et de
son pagny bleus pour encourager les
achats locaux à accélérer la demande de
paniers un peu partout au québec est
vraiment une explosion au niveau des
abonnements
on va avoir une année à 432 fermes font
partie du réseau québécois des fermiers
de famille
leur objectif était de nourrir 21500
famille cet été
il est déjà atteint et sera dépassé de
plusieurs milliers en ce moment il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de fermes qui sont
complètes
il reste quelques places est important
de dire aux gens d'aller voir quand même
de persévérer de s'inscrire sur des
listes d'attentes
contrairement aux gros producteurs gérer
la menace du coronavirus n'est pas
difficile pour johan qui compte
seulement six employés elle a d'ailleurs
dit non à plusieurs personnes qui
souhaitaient travailler pour elle les
fermes bio ont la cote au québec et
profite de ce printemps de pandémie nous
on s'engage pendant les 20 prochaines
semaines à vous livrer une valeur
déterminée de légumes c'est ça amène une
sécurité j'appuie on est encore dans le
légume frais locales aussi un légume que
pas été manipulée on a un lien de
proximité avec notre agriculteur la
salubrité la traçabilité on sait comment
sont produits non légumes
d'où ils viennent le forfait est offert
par johan pour fournir des légumes à une
famille de deux ou trois personnes tout
l'été coûte 620 dollars le google ont
fait des annonces qu'il faut développer
une autonomie alimentaire
on espère qu'il va tenir son discours
pour le après pandémie parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle
pouvoir plus facilement acheter de
petites terres et diversifier leur offre
avec par exemple plus de neuf ou de
poulet voilà deux revendications et
fermiers de famille ils ont le vent dans
les voiles mais auront besoin de québec
pour continuer de grossir
[Musique]